well ever dream of driving a rolls-royce
ferrari or lamborghini
plenty of people do and you are in look
at all star cars they can make that
dream a reality jc fernandez joins us
live with the details hey jc great
assignment on a friday
perfect assignment and kirsten i found
the perfect car for you this is the
rolls-royce colleen am i saying that
right jp
cullinan calling in this is the
rolls-royce suv
this is jimmy with all-star car rentals
you can rent this vehicle how does the
whole process work
so basically this is our flagship here
at all-star cars
the conan is about two thousand dollars
a day once we verify your insurance
we make some more things uh figured out
with your license
you can have this for for the day look
at look what comes inside of course
there's a rolls royce it's going to rain
in vegas you got to have the umbrella
you have an unbelievable collection of
cars uh so
the thing about the rolls royce is the
hood emblem and this is known
as the spirit of ecstasy correct and
show everyone the trick
it disappears so no one can steal it it
goes away
you have everything you've got the
rolls-royce suv you've got exotic cars
and you've got
muscle cars what do we have here this
will be the dodge challenger hellcat
redeye
about 797 horsepower and you can rent
this how much does this go for a day
this is about 6.99 a day ready excuse me
ready
[Music]
listen
all american muscle right here and how
fast does this car go
this car will do probably close to 200
miles an hour close to 200 miles per
hour
now who's coming out of ren of these
vehicles from you guys anyone and
everyone we have from
international to local
to any state you can imagine and you do
have you do have everything and i was on
your website earlier today
you just go shopping for the car you
want let's spin it around and go back
here
and take a look at this corvette this is
a 2020 stingray correct
and tell me about this one how much does
the corvette go for this is uh 699 as
well it might be 7.99 don't quote me if
i'm wrong
um but this is the first mid-engine
corvette and it's the c8 model
which is extremely comfortable about 495
horsepower you could probably do about
170 in this
and what i like about your guys's
service is you go to the website there's
no hidden fees
how many miles does someone get per day
on this basically about 120 per day on
the vehicles
and we can arrange it where you can go
further if you like
now this too this has the uh it has
what's it's the frunk
the front i guess you could say the
trunk up front because the engine
and it's got the trunk in the back you
can fit two sets of golf clubs in the
back of this thing but if you're renting
this
the front you're in the front of the
ball comes if you're renting this thing
you're not gonna go to the golf course
you're gonna be on the 215.
i'm guessing you're gonna be driving
you're gonna be cruising not driving a
golf ball and then spin around look you
want to rent an
nsx you guys can rent one as well you
guys have everything here i'm in heaven
how much does the nsx go for sex is 4.99
today
can't go wrong with a supercar for 4.99
today and just a little check out
what color what color is this it's a
nardo gray
and this is a wrap it's not a paint job
this is a wrap on this car it's a
beautiful piece of machinery
and coming up we're going to show you
some bentleys
and we have one of the top-of-the-line
wranglers that you guys can rent as well
and we'll showcase that
that much and more is coming up we'll
send it back to you guys in the studio
yeah jc i know you love the muscle cars
is hellcat your favorite so far
the hellcat yeah yeah the hellcat is
pretty
it's pretty intense it's pretty it's
pretty fast it's pretty fast do i have a
second because actually with the hellcat
the hellcat you get two keys there's the
black key and when you start it
you can access 500 horsepower but
there's a red key when you start it you
get the 790 horsepower wow
well we have a friend who has one of
those you can hear him from several
blocks away
and um i wasn't so sure that his wife
was so excited about his purchase but he
still has it
all right jc we'll check in with you
momentarily